welcome to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast in this
episode we discussed a variety of topics
including the effects of birth control
in the menstrual cycle on periodization
the concept of dietary fat cycling in
the time course of muscle and connective
tissue adaptations to training Greg also
gives some good tips on how to turn a
good hypertrophy program into a strength
program and how to keep a neutral pelvis
while squatting and dead lifting thanks
for listening and enjoy the episode
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host Aaron Trexler
and one man can't do it all on a podcast
so my assistant today is Greg knuckles
Greg thanks for coming by thanks for
having me on now we are recording this
episode the day after two days after
days off two days after the United
States put an absolute whooping on the
Netherlands in the Women's World Cup and
we want to use that opportunity to let
everybody in the Netherlands know that
you're a joke you're your clown yeah so
it was great that the US women won it
was especially sweet though that they
won over the Netherlands so we joke
around a lot on the show but I'm going
to give you a sneak peek into some very
real completely honest analytics that we
have for favorability of this podcast so
after we released the first episode seen
as this is the first fitness podcast you
know we didn't really know what we were
doing we didn't have anything to compare
it to so we just kind of put it out
there ask people what did you think what
are some things we did well what are
some things we can improve on and most
of the feedback was overwhelmingly
positive however we did have four very
very critical pieces of feedback like
messages from for people who just just
really really disliked the podcast it
was like a visceral level of dislike
yeah it was yeah and and I mean we had
hundreds of responses and only four were
like very very negative all four were
Dutch people
and we checked our listener statistics
we had we had 11 downloads from the
Netherlands so what I'm saying here is
we are not instigating conflict with the
Dutch the Dutch have already instigated
conflict with us this is officially a
podcast that is Pro Fitness pro science
anti Netherlands absolutely yeah so you
know putting you guys on notice just as
our women's soccer team took your
women's soccer team down we will take
you down if you choose to escalate this
conflict and it's worth mentioning we're
basically playing with house money by
waging this because we only stand to
lose I think three listeners if we just
yeah we leave we had eleven four of them
hated us we have seven left whatever
alright so getting down to business
this is a question-and-answer episode we
get the questions from you guys and then
we answer them so the first question is
for Greg the username a kook that's
gonna work for now the question is how
do birth control and menstrual cycle
hormones interact to affect
periodization should I program with that
in mind
okay so first kind of the assumption
behind this question I would assume is
that in and if this wasn't the askers
assumptions this this should have been
the askers assumptions is throughout the
menstrual cycle female sex hormones
change particularly estrogen and
progesterone and to massively simplify a
bunch of physiology here estrogen is
good progesterone not necessarily bad
but largely counteracts the positive
effects of estrogen the positive effects
of estrogen being largely glycogen
sparing helps with muscle recovery
pretty good at reducing levels of
inflammation post-training
pretty good stuff progesterone largely
largely counters that
so over the course of a menstrual cycle
starting Edmund sees levels of estrogen
and progesterone are pretty low
throughout the first half of the
menstrual cycle estrogen levels
gradually increase progesterone levels
stay quite low around opulence lightly
before ovulation which is around the
midpoint of the cycle progesterone
levels start increasing and throughout
the second half of the cycle during the
luteal phase both estrogen and
progesterone levels are fairly high
until menses begins and then they both
drop off so so one would see that and
assume that during the follicular phase
and particularly like the second half of
the follicular phase when progesterone
is still low and estrogen is starting to
increase maybe training would go a
little bit better than and in fact that
is what we've seen in a handful of
studies three or four to this point the
way all of those studies were set up is
essentially they'd have one group
training with low volume or low
frequency during the luteal phase and
high volume and high frequency during
the luteal phase or vice-versa and see
what the effects were on strength and
hypertrophy and what all of those
studies found is that by doing more
training during the follicular phase
rather than the luteal phase the women
got better results gain more strength
grew more muscle so that confirms the
theory that you know largely training
when progesterone levels are lower you
you may have a slightly higher return on
investment there one weakness of those
studies is there wasn't another
condition where it's just keep volume
and frequency high the whole month which
one would assume would be better than
just training hard two weeks out of the
month so there's also some data
indicating that women recover a little
bit faster during the follicular phase
so that research is from Markovski at
all 2014 so so basically it does seem
like women
recover a little bit faster from
training during the follicular phase
which is the first two weeks of the
cycle and may just respond to training a
little bit better during the follicular
phase but I don't necessarily think you
need to go completely out of you out of
your way to program around that I think
most people kind of program their mezzo
cycles in kind of month blocks in the
first place with maybe a D load week
worked in there somewhere or at least a
week that's slightly easier so it may
not be a bad idea to have maybe your
higher volume weeks of training during
the follicular phase and if you do have
a deal owed week every month make sure
that that's during the luteal phase but
I don't think it's something you really
need to move heaven and earth to program
around so that's kind of like the
average answer another thing worth
noting is that subjective assessments
from women about how they perform and
how they recover throughout their
menstrual cycle research that's just
surveyed female athletes to ask like hey
how do you perform how does your
training go at different points in the
cycle that stuff's all over the place so
what I said is kind of like the average
response that we see in the research but
individual female athletes what actually
works best for the individual may differ
considerably from that so that's the
menstrual cycle when you throw birth
control into the equation it gets a lot
Messier
because it largely depends on what kind
of birth control formulation you're
using there's also less research on that
so there are a few studies just
comparing training on birth control to
not on birth control but I haven't seen
studies based on you know training
during a high hormone phase of like your
monthly birth control cycle versus a
local hormone phase and things may
respond a little bit differently with
like in bauman asleep reduced hormones
versus exogenously ingested synthetic
hormones so it's it's kind of hard to
say with birth control one thing I will
say though is that
there is still there is still like a
pretty strong belief among a lot of
female athletes that birth control
decreases training adaptations decreases
strength gains decreases hypertrophy and
that was probably true like 20 years ago
one one important thing to note about
the progression of birth control is so
like I mentioned progesterone you know
not bad but largely counteracts the
beneficial effects of estrogen and so
progesterone itself isn't in birth
controls there are different progestins
that are not exactly the same as
progesterone but have similar effects
and those progestins have different
levels of androgen isset ii and so you
hear androgen isset ii and you think Oh
kind of like androgen and anabolic
steroids but it's actually the opposite
so progestins can bind to the androgen
receptor and kind of stop testosterone
from doing what it would otherwise do at
that receptor so the more androgenic a
progestin is the worse it probably is
for female athletes and the birth
controls that were popular in the 70s
and 80s the formulations used much much
more androgenic progestins than what's
used in birth control now and so the
early studies looking at the effects of
birth control on hypertrophy strength
gains did largely find that there were
negative effects the more recent
research probably on women taking like
more recently formulated versions of
birth control largely finds no
difference so i think that i think that
that is currently a myth that didn't
used to be a myth so I think back in the
day when women took birth control it did
probably decrease training adaptations
to some degree these days it probably
doesn't just because the the
formulations use less androgenic
progestins
one one area where that may differ is
again in surveys on elite female
athletes the type of birth control that
is frequently given the most strongly
negative subjective ratings is
progesterone injections or progestin
injections I think the most the most
common like brand name formulation it's
called depo-provera
so anyway like I'm certainly not telling
female athletes to not use progesterone
injections but that if if there is a
form of birth control that is most
commonly implicated in negative effects
on female athletes in the modern day
it's probably that one so you know don't
take don't take birth control advice
from a dude on a podcast that's a
conversation to have with your doctor
but that is potentially a conversation
worth having okay so next question for
you Eric is it known if there is a
optimal rate of fat loss for maintaining
performance as best you can so for
example the common guideline of about
one percent of body mass per week or per
month or whatever the questioner asks
basically what is the optimal rate of
fat loss oh you know you don't spend
forever cutting but you don't lose too
much muscle don't compromise performance
too much and this question is from
obi-wan trinova well it's tough because
it anytime you talk about rate of weight
loss it depends on where you're starting
where you're going and why you're doing
it you know so if you are losing weight
because you think it will actually
improve your performance in your pursuit
then certainly you would want to lose
weight in a fairly expeditious manner
you know so if you think you're carrying
way too much body fat to be effective in
your sport or to be as competitive as
you want to be then that might influence
the rate of weight loss if you're like
hey I got to get down there and compete
now now another thing is maybe you're
doing just fine competitively you're
performing the way you want but for
health reasons
you're like long-term I'd like to
maintain a lower body fat if that's the
case you might take a slower approach
and really take essentially play the
long game and say if we want to maintain
this weight loss let's take our time and
do it right a third factor to consider
is if you do a slow weight loss phase
sometimes you find if you go really slow
with weight loss people get they get a
little bit impatient and the lack the
lack of significant progress is actually
a demotivating effect where because the
weight loss is taking a long time even
though that's generally more sustainable
they just quit earlier because they're
like I've been trying to lose weight for
two months and I've only lost four and a
half pounds or something like that now
to get directly to the point
to generalize usually you want your rate
of weight loss to be somewhere between
0.5 and one point zero percent of body
mass per week that's usually a rate of
weight loss that will be rapid enough to
get the job done in a reasonable
timeframe for most people you'll see
changes on the scale rapid enough to
keep you interested and motivated and
provide some reassurance that you're
actually on the right track but you
generally speaking don't want to go too
far beyond that when you start to get to
rates of excessive speed when it comes
to weight loss you start to see a
greater likelihood that performance will
take a dip that you might have slightly
less favorable changes in the exact
composition of weight that was lost so
there are some studies showing that a
more rapid approach to weight loss you
might lose similar amounts of weight but
the more rapid approach might lose more
lean tissue and less fat tissue there's
also I think Tina Garth I don't know if
I'm pronouncing her last name right but
I know she did a study years back that
was really fantastic they took a ton of
different performance and body compound
and marija lehigh quality study showing
that generally speaking excessive rates
of fat loss in athletes or rates of
weight loss I should say probably are
not the optimal approach assuming that
you have time to spend and I think that
study was looking at 0.7 percent versus
1.4 percent of harass per week correct
yeah and they found that pretty much
across the war across the board point
seven percent yielded better outcomes in
general it was certainly a short-term
study I think I think it was like five
and eight weeks respectively yeah for it
for the total duration of weight loss
but but generally speaking once you
start getting above one percent per week
you increase the likelihood that you
might induce some more severe changes
when it comes to hormone balance so
potentially greater drops in
testosterone and other hormones that
change with weight loss potentially you
might see greater reductions in
performance a greater proportion of lean
mass lost certainly there are exceptions
to that especially if you have a lot of
fat to lose that's a case where you can
probably get away with a little maybe
going a little bit higher than that just
to get the process going but that's
usually the range I shoot for 0.5 to 1
ok question for Greg here from there on
spud I think it's the iron spud Jesus
that's an embarrassing way to miss read
that I I thought you were just joking
and I wasn't picking up on it I wish I
was joking it's been a long day Ivan
yeah my brain is fried right it's all
good it's all good
the beef the irons but the thing is I'm
just used to these these user names
being gibberish that I it's like I don't
even interpret them in real-time anymore
just like here's some syllables all
right the iron spud any tips on
maintaining a neutral pelvis in the
squat and the deadlift anterior pelvic
tilt is murdering my hamstrings yes so
that's um that's actually not too common
and lifters and so just to start with
one thing that I want to make clear is
there are a lot of very hot takes out
there about anterior pelvic tilt neutral
pelvis have like you know ribs down
cylinder between your ribs and pelvis
and whatnot there's not particularly
strong evidence for any of that the
neutral pelvis is necessarily better
that anterior pelvic tilt is bad so I'm
answering this question with the
assumption that someone has a lot of
anterior pelvic tilt that's causing
problems for them or they just want to
try something else and they're having
trouble trying something else just
because of how ingrained anterior pelvic
tilt is for them just as background so
this is pretty common in lifters so one
of the things that most people learn
first day in the gym is you don't want
your back to flex under load and so
people extend their spine to the point
of hyper extending and when you you know
are trying to extend your lumbar spine
really hard generally that comes with
anterior pelvic tilt of the pelvis so
what can you do to try to get back
towards neutral pelvis I think one of
the first things you can do is just get
into neutral pelvis or posterior pelvic
tilt positions just so it gives you like
a conscious feeling of what that feels
like kind of gives your nervous system a
feeling of what that feels like in ways
that are going to be non-threatening so
some things that I think are pretty good
for that are like either body weight or
very very light weight hip thrust or
glute bridges where you're like very
very purposefully just using your glutes
like maybe tensing your abs as well and
really trying to get into posterior
pelvic tilt another thing that I think
is pretty useful for that as well as
dead bugs making sure you're doing them
very very strictly getting into
posterior pelvic tilt keeping your back
flat on the ground not letting your
lumbar spine
come up off the ground as you do them so
only going down with with your leg as
far as you can before your back starts
coming up so yeah just kind of getting
into those positions and in graining
them in a non-threatening way I think is
the first place you would start then
another thing that just anecdotally
seems to help a lot of people for
reasons I'm not entirely sure of is like
before you pull a deadlift or before you
descend on a squat just squeeze your
gluts really really hard so like before
you bend down to pick up the bar for a
deadlift
like squeeze your glutes put yourself in
posterior pelvic tilt like before you
pick the bar up and then set up and
deadlift as you normally would but a lot
of people find that just squeezing their
glutes really hard and putting
themselves in more like posterior pelvic
tilt or a neutral pelvis position prior
to setting up for the lift even if if
they're going back like neutral spine or
lumbar extension for the lift itself
they find that that helps put them in a
slightly more neutral position for the
squat it would be after you unrack the
bar but before you start descending and
then finally like if those things don't
really do it for you just practice with
light weight so that's kind of assuming
you can get to a neutral pelvis position
in the first place so some people just
don't have the motor control for it and
for them it is mostly just like reap at
earning doing things that do put you in
a neutral pelvis or posterior pelvic
tilt position and just in graining that
position until you can consciously
access it for movements like squats and
deadlifts instead of like literally not
being able to get into that position
once you do have access to it then it's
just a matter of you know starting with
manageable weights and just practicing
the new positioning you want to ingrain
so you know nothing magical nothing
special but those are the tips that I
would give
okay question for Eric from Leonor Zia
just as during a fat loss phase it is
recommended to recalculate maintenance
calories and adjust the deficit
accordingly is it beneficial to do the
same thing in Reverse for a mass phase
or where the calorie surplus become too
high too quickly just a little
terminology update we're gonna call it a
bulking phase because everybody knows
mass is the premier research review in
the fitness world so we're gonna reserve
that term purely for the publication
okay all right with that out of the way
bulking phase should we be recalculating
maintenance to inform our caloric intake
the answer is yes because theoretically
it's basically the same thing so the
reason we recalculate maintenance during
a deficit is because as we lose weight
that maintenance level changes and some
of that is because of losses in body
mass and some of that is adaptive in
nature so total energy expenditure drops
even more than we would predict based on
body mass changes alone now what we see
is that during weight gain in a bulking
phase or a massing phase is that the
inverse happens so as we gain weight
certainly our caloric needs are
increased bigger bodies need more
calories to run but we also see that in
some people there is a pretty pronounced
adaptive increase in energy expenditure
and the cool thing about that is there's
research demonstrating it several times
over several different studies showing
that some people when you over feed them
and induce weight gain they actually
resist it quite a bit
their appetite disappears their total
energy expenditure goes up way more than
you would expect and they are quite
resistant to gaining weight during over
feeding now if you've ever identified as
a hard gainer and you're like no matter
how much I eat I just can't gain weight
you're probably one of those people like
these people have shown up in the
research the unfortunate thing is a lot
of people don't display such a robust
response to over feeding and when you
over feed them their body is very happy
to go ahead and store that as fat and
keep it so the thing that makes that
challenging is because it's quite
variable and that variability has been
shown in the literature it's hard to
give a general guideline in terms of how
much to expect total energy expenditure
to increase when you overfeed but
nonetheless theoretically it's the same
exact scenario just in the opposite
direction as you overfeed during a bulk
you would expect just from weight gain
alone that your caloric needs would go
up and your maintenance level would
change but even more so some people are
quite resistant to to weight gain during
over feeding doesn't make it impossible
it just means that their body's gonna
try to resist that by shutting down the
appetite and increasing the energy
expenditure so some people will have to
overfeed more than they expected to gain
a similar amount of weight during a bulk
now though the the the generalized
advice I could give
in terms of weight gain is to and Eric
Helms and colleagues I think the lead
author was it was uh Iraqi right maybe
he has a podcast yeah not really a
fitness well I wouldn't call the podcast
Juma Iraq yeah yeah he's the lead author
it's not a fitness podcast but he was
the lead author on on a paper with Helms
and a couple other people recently on
offseason recommendations for
bodybuilders and you know they give the
target weight gain value of about 0.25
to 0.5% of body weight per week so I
mean the easiest way to do it in my
opinion is you start you start your bulk
you shoot for somewhere in that range
depending on how aggressive you want to
be you keep an eye on how your body
weights changing and if it's not
increasing that fast
you increase the calories a little bit I
don't think it requires a formal
estimation of how much is maintenance
and how much then would be my exact
surplus I like to just be consistent
with my calories
take a reliable morning weight look at
average is over a few days in a row and
to make my decisions accordingly in
terms of how much I need to increase or
decrease my calories but I think a safe
bet would be shoot for that range of
weight gain 0.25 to 0.5% of body weight
per week and if you're gaining weight to
quickly drop the calories a bit if
you're not gaining quickly enough
increase them and I think that should
about do it okay I've got a question for
Greg here actually it's not a question
it's a statement that we are going to
use as a prompt for Greg to elaborate
from Mika the delayed adaptive response
of connective tissue to resistance
training sure begin you know just slap a
question mark on there and end with an
up inflection and you're good to go so
I'm just gonna ramble about connective
tissue for a bit so when people talk
about connective tissue they're
primarily I think talking about the the
collagen that composes your tendons so
there's some evidence that other
collagenous structures so I'm thinking
here ligaments or possibly cartilage
intervertebral discs there's some
research showing that those things can
also respond to training but when most
people ask about connective tissue
adaptation more often than not they're
asking about tendons and so interesting
stuff about tendons one of the cool
things is that when people think about
tendons they think of it as something
distinct from muscle that's just kind of
chilling out on the end of a muscle kind
of doing its thing but tendons actually
the entire must musculoskeletal system
is super inner woven to a degree that I
don't think people fully appreciate so
well I was gonna say like in the more
academic applications when you talk
about it you talk about the muscle
tendon unit like you've rarely the more
academic inclination is to not even
distinguish really between the muscle
and the tendon yeah you know so yeah so
you
have a ton of connective tissue
completely running through all of your
muscles
they're called your endomysium
perimysium epimysium all of those things
are are continuous with the tendon
itself the tendon itself is connective
with or is continuous with collagenous
structures that also run through your
bone so it's not just like it's it's
glued to your bone in one spot like your
bones and tendons are completely woven
together as well it's all one continuous
thing woven together by collagen which i
think is super super cool but so in
terms of tendinous adaptations and
collagenous adaptations within the
muscular tendinous unit two training one
of the things I think is poorly
understood and poorly appreciated is the
within muscle collagen and connective
tissue and how that responds to training
so something that was proposed way back
in the 80s in a review paper by
Rutherford and Jones is that the the
connections between connective tissue
and individual muscle fibers would
increase with resistance training that
would aid in lateral force transmission
from the muscle fibers to the connective
tissue main matrix throughout the muscle
which would help with force transfer to
the tendons and thus essentially for any
given level of motor unit recruitment
and activation and actual muscle
contraction you would get more force
actually making it to the tendon to
create larger joint moments that I don't
think has been directly studied in
humans just looking to see how many of
like those adhesions there were between
muscle fibers and connective tissue but
there is some like indirect evidence I'm
particularly thinking of a 2010 study by
Erskine and colleagues which found the
types of performance based adaptations
that one would expect were that
occurring so
one of the cool offshoots of that and I
think I think this is super cool is the
amount of force your muscles can produce
per unit of cross-sectional area is
actually greater than the amount of
force that your muscle fibers produce
per unit of cross-sectional area which
is super unintuitive but is probably due
to that lateral force transmission and
like enhanced transmission to the
tendons via that connective tissue
running throughout the muscle so those
adaptations actually seem to take place
pretty early in the training process
contrary to the assumed question asking
about delayed adaptive response but I
just think that's super cool and I like
to get it out there as often as possible
that when we when we talk about
connective tissue changes it's not just
tendons ligaments cartilage it's also
connective tissue within the muscle
which actually has like pretty big
effects on actual performance outcomes
then in terms of tendons themselves
there's some evidence actually there's
quite a bit of evidence that like
trained strength trained lifters or
particularly I'm thinking of a couple
studies on weight lifters that they're
like quadriceps tendons are thicker than
those of untrained people it is assumed
that that means that those tendons got
thicker over time you can't necessarily
infer that from a cross-sectional study
but that that is the assumption people
make a lot of the longitudinal studies
looking to see however whether tendons
actually do thicken with training
largely find that they don't but it's
probably due to the fact that collagen
turnover in tendons is just so slow
here's a fun little fact collagen
turnover in tendons is so slow that if a
dead body is found that is old enough
that they were alive during the time of
atomic testing you can actually tell how
old they were
like how deep into their into their
Achilles tendon like different isotopes
are found which I think is wild is that
assuming they live near common test
sites or was it that ubiquitous that it
was a lot of the testing was in the
atmosphere until a treaty like in the
70s or 80s the banned atmospheric
testing so so so yeah like total levels
of radiation that were like background
radiation who we're exposed to today is
lower than it was during the time that
people are actually like testing a bunch
of nukes yeah and so like based on how
deeply I was gonna say we don't test
atomic stuff up there anymore but we do
have chemtrails to to work with that is
true it's not all good yeah anyway but
so tendon turnover is pretty slow
tendons do absolutely adapt to training
a lot of the adaptations are more in
like how the collagen itself is oriented
versus how much of it there actually is
collagen is really [ __ ] strong like
to to an extent that I don't think
people fully appreciate and so like when
it comes to connective tissue
adaptations I think a lot of people are
looking to see like do my tendons get
thicker but your tendons are probably
already thick enough and strong enough
to deal with the forces you put on them
for the most part unless you have some
sort of pathology but one of the things
that does occur both with training and
also with rehab like if you do have a
tendon injury and then you know you
immobilize it and then start training
again is you get better orientation of
those collagen fibers such that they
align better with the line of force and
so the closer to like perfectly parallel
they are the better they'll be able to
transmit force in the more tensile
strength they'll have so that's an
adaptation that occurs but if you're
interested in actual like tendon
hypertrophy one I don't think you
necessarily need to be that interested
in it just because tendons are so strong
in the first place and too
if it does occur we're talking about
like it's hard to measure muscle
hypertrophy and trained lifters on the
timescale of months so when we're
talking about tendon hypertrophy like
when you look at collagen synthesis
after training versus protein synthesis
you get way bigger spikes in muscle
protein synthesis than collagen
synthesis and so like you're probably
talking about adaptations that would
take place on the timescale of years
versus months so I mean the question
asked about delayed adaptive response if
there is actual like longitudinal
hypertrophy taking place it is probably
quite delayed possibly a little quicker
for untrained lifters but we're talking
you know for measurable increases to
occur it probably takes minimum months
likely years now along the lines of that
question I've heard rumblings I kind of
went straight into natural bodybuilding
like I never really hung with a crew
that was into the more steroid accepting
world of bodybuilding but I've always
heard that one of the risks you run with
with the drug use and really heavy
periods of training is a higher risk of
connective tissue injury because of the
rapid increases in strength and like a
delayed basically the idea that the
adaptive responses of connective tissue
can't quite keep up with the ever
increasing loads is there any any merit
to that I mean that's entirely possible
yeah I mean I could I could see that
being the case actually I remember
coming across a paper maybe like three
years ago or so that was investigating
whether there were differences in injury
rates or injury risk between drug-free
lifters and lifters on steroids and I
don't remember why but one of the parts
of the study is they took quadriceps or
like a knee extensor in the
so they had people kick against an
immovable resistance as hard as possible
and I remember I remember the results of
the study as they said oh it doesn't
seem to be any increased injury risk in
these people on steroids but one of the
things they noted is there were like two
complete quad tendon ruptures during the
MVC's for the people on steroids uh-huh
but then I think they were excluded from
the study because of that so that makes
you kind of wonder cuz like I've never
heard of anyone getting a complete
tendon rupture during an MVC no I mean
that's like so so like maybe that's your
first clue there buddy but another thing
I'll note here in in now I'm I'm
definitely extrapolating to some degree
but in studies on injury rates and
strength Sports one of the things you
see is that a strongman consistently has
the highest rates of injury and
strongman to the best of my knowledge
does not have a drug-free division like
there are absolutely strongman
competitors who are drug-free but
there's not an equivalent to the IPF but
they compete drug-free at their own risk
essentially yeah pretty much so I mean
maybe that's a factor there I think part
of it is just strongman itself is
inherently more dangerous than
powerlifting and weightlifting is that
you know maybe a larger percentage of
the total pool of athletes using
steroids like maybe that contributes to
the increased injury risk as well but
the one of one of the other interesting
things one of the interesting things
about peds and potential risks to too
soft issues that I don't think people
talk about enough is one of the things
that you'll often see people discuss in
the context of professional athletes is
like oh these guys are coming back from
injury way quicker because you know like
they're using growth hormone when
they're not being drug tested and it is
true that growth hormone increases
collagen synthesis but
in so like I mentioned before your
collagen is strongest when all of those
fibers are oriented correctly with the
line of force and so when new collagen
is laid down its kind of laid down all
willy-nilly and you have to expose it to
load for it to kind of gradually
straighten out over time and so there
have been studies in mice where they put
them on high levels of growth hormone
and then test tendon strength and it
actually makes the tendons considerably
more brittle because they're laying down
a bunch of new collagen but it's not
oriented correctly and so they're more
susceptible to tendon ruptures and so
like theoretically if you use growth
hormone got thicker tendons spent
considerable amounts of time
conditioning them making sure all of the
collagen fibers were arranged correctly
in parallel to each other that should I
guess theoretically create a stronger
tendon but you know maybe a factor there
is just kind of willy-nilly growth
hormone usage and people laying down a
bunch of new tendon that's not as strong
because the collagen fibers are oriented
in a bunch of different directions you
know it's interesting that you brought
it there with the growth hormone because
when you look at the the clinical
research available on growth hormone
administration it doesn't appear to be
that great for hypertrophy of skeletal
muscle the studies i've seen generally
show that it increases the growth of
connective tissue but not not much
hypertrophy when it comes to skeletal
muscle for young people okay is it
different in old people yeah I believe
like people haven't really studied
growth hormone for like urgh agenda
effects since the 90s right but I think
around the time that years cherish
Chesky found that it doesn't do much for
young people either either that same lab
group or like another lab group
concurrently did similar studies on
older men I believe and found that
growth hormone injections did increase
hypertrophy in older
people because one of the things that
that happens is one of the main triggers
for growth hormone release is melatonin
and as you get older and your pineal
gland ages he produced less melatonin
and so you get smaller growth hormone
excursions during the night and so like
old people just have considerably lower
growth hormone levels than younger
people do and so that's kind of logical
like young people seem to have as much
growth hormone as they need yeah older
people may benefit kind of in the same
way that they would from TRT right so
the thing that interested me was you
hear about all these relatively young
athletes who are allegedly using growth
hormone at a reasonably high level or
you know high prevalence theoretically
and I've always wondered if what they
were really trying to get out of it was
maybe a little boost when it comes to
connective tissue either preventing
injury or trying to accommodate some of
the growth associated with other peds
that have a more direct effect of
skeletal muscle hypertrophy but I had
never heard that that research in
rodents indicating that it made those
connective tissues paradoxically more
brittle yeah I mean I'm sure as with
anything else the dose makes the poison
yeah it's been a long time since I read
that study in rodents they very well may
have been using absolutely ridiculous
dosages yeah and it could be one of
those things where if your resistance
training as you're doing it the collagen
aligns itself kind of in real time as
you lay it down and things work out okay
yeah I was just kind of throwing that
out there as a potential risk that I
don't think a lot of people are aware of
no I mean it's really interesting and it
just it adds another layer of you know
I've just I've always wondered it's like
people that aren't really that into
sport at a high level they always like
talk about Oh somebody's on HGH like
they throw it out all the time and I've
always wondered how prevalent it really
is in professional sport but
also like what what is the real direct
benefit that's getting obtained from it
you know I mean yeah yeah I mean it's
hard to say it sucks because you'd like
the the the anecdotal thing that I'm
sure we've all heard is that it really
only does stuff if you're also taking
steroids
yeah with it and growth hormone and
insulin are two of the things attributed
to bodybuilders like really blowing up
in the late 90s early 2000s yeah so I
mean you know if if all of the people in
the world who are building the most
muscle all say like oh yes this is a key
to getting big rainy sighs then like I'm
not gonna say they're wrong yeah but
you're right like in isolation growth
hormone doesn't really seem to do much
yeah to be fair those are also the
people who told us that uh you know
arginine and glutamine are are really
key to muscle growth as well they were
paid to do it yeah I mean there's a
difference between what people are paid
to say versus like what they actually do
to be successful at their sport yeah
yeah but no we went off on a little bit
of a tangent but a growth hormone has
always just intrigued me because you
hear about it as if it's used at a
reasonably high prevalence in high level
you know bodybuilding or professional
sport and it's always just intrigued me
like exactly what are people getting out
of it well I mean it wouldn't surprise
me if it's somewhat popular cuz I think
at that level
some people just look for like look what
can I take to potentially give me a
marginal edge that I'm unlikely to get
busted for yeah and we talked about this
in the last episode modern drug testing
for steroids has gotten considerably
better testing for peptide hormones has
also gotten better but not to the same
degree largely because so with steroids
you can do carbon isotope ratio testing
you can't do the same thing on peptide
hormones most of the peptide hormones
that people would use are bio
identical to what you put in your body
with growth hormones specifically
there's such large daily excursions in
growth hormone level because it's
released in a pulsatile fashion that
it's hard to just unless someone like
literally just injected it's hard to
look at the actual levels of growth
hormone in the blood and say this is
unnatural and similar with with EPO as
well and also like growth hormone and
EPO both have really really short
half-lives and so you know unless you
inject it and then wada knocks on your
door 15 minutes later you're probably
gonna be fine so I do think testing for
that has improved if anyone remembers
patent Mendes from back in the day very
promising young super heavyweight
weightlifter yeah I remember him he got
busted for growth hormone twice so like
either he got super unlucky twice in a
row or like the testing is is improving
for that as well but but I do know that
it's still easier for people to get away
with using peptides of which growth
hormone is one than using steroids so it
could be one of those things where you
know may not have huge effects but maybe
there's some some marginal benefits and
you know people are gravitating to that
because they think you know maybe I'll
get a little something out of it and I'm
less likely to get popped yeah all right
DB math eats asks what is the current
scientific consensus or your thoughts
based on anecdotes related to weakly fat
distribution in the diet and its effects
on strength hypertrophy or fat loss for
example what having a static 0.3 grams
per pound a daily be superior for
hormonal balance / performance / fat
loss etc compared to having days lower
or higher than average throughout the
week parentheses in essence fat cycling
so essentially you know what do you do
when you're setting fat intake
for a client the question of whenever
you have a question about nutrient
timing of any type it's important to
consider what is this nutrient really
doing for you and is there a temporal
component of that function and so what I
mean by that is we can intuitively say
does protein timing matter absolutely if
you had all your protein once every
fortnight you know if you had just a
god-awful amount of protein one day and
then just didn't have protein for 13
days that'd be a really dumb way to do
it because of what protein is doing for
us eating it in a possibly serpentine
fashion exactly yes so we know that our
body is constantly breaking down
proteins and we need to replace those
proteins we have turnover going on all
the time so obviously there is some
temporal aspect of the fact that we have
continuous protein breakdown and we
ought to have at least semi continuous
provision of new proteins to to help
offset that breakdown when it comes to
carbohydrate carbohydrate cycling is
fairly intuitive for certain
applications because what is
carbohydrate do for us it provides
energy and more importantly or more
directly provides energy when we're
doing really glycogen depleting bouts of
exercise so you could at least
understand why there would be a temporal
component of that as well for athletes
of hey if if you can't go high carb
every day but you have a particularly
important workout situating
carbohydrates somewhere with within the
week 2 to really strategically target
that that makes a lot of sense now with
fat what are we eating fat for certainly
there are essential fatty acids that we
must get from the diet that our body
doesn't have the enzymatic machinery to
produce from other fatty acids so that's
one thing fat intake allows us to
assists with the absorption of fat
soluble vitamins it's an important
component of cholesterol and certain
hormones and cell membranes
so we certainly need it but I'm not
familiar with much much research at all
looking at the concept of fat cycling
because while we would be aware that we
need it and that we probably ought to
have it on a fairly regular basis I
can't really off the top of my head
think of a strategic way to leverage
that into a particular timing protocol
I would think generally you'd want it
daily just to facilitate the day-to-day
replenishment of the need for those
fatty acids and to facilitate regular
absorption of fat soluble vitamins
although theoretically you could hold on
to those fat soluble vitamins for quite
awhile I mean you you can build up a
little bit of a storage of them but the
question to me or the question that
comes to my mind is how would you
leverage this in a strategic way it
would seem to me that the most
parsimonious approach the simplest and
most straightforward would be just set
your fat intake and leave it on a daily
basis so that's usually my inclination I
usually recommend to my my clients and
with my own diet I rarely let fat get
below 0.6 or 0.7 grams per kilogram of
body mass I know some people that are
comfortable getting down to 0.5 is there
a huge difference between 0.5 0.6
probably not but for me for whatever
reason my line in the sand is at point 6
I don't like going below that now the
only the only way I could kind of see it
making any sense and I could be missing
something but maybe if you are
strategically trying to really emphasize
emphasize carbohydrate on a particular
day and in order to make that work
calorically you you want to maybe lower
the fat that day and then increase the
fat a different day if you want to for
some reason really pump a single day
full of carbohydrate without having a
totally nonlinear caloric intake day to
day maybe it makes sense that some of
those carbs are displacing fat and
you're going to catch up with that on
the backend later in the week but
generally speaking I
this is making fat intake a lot more
complicated than it ought to be so it'd
be more of like a secondary effect from
manipulating other macronutrients versus
right doing it to specifically
manipulate fat yeah I mean I could be
missing something and if you have ideas
I'd be thrilled to hear them I I can't
think of a strategic way that I would
leverage my fat intake for a particular
benefit yeah I mean if if we're getting
like super theoretical into the into the
realm of stuff that no people actually
do what you mentioned of like a super
high carb day may make sense so I
believe in the last episode maybe two
episodes ago we talked about de novo
lipogenesis
a little bit correct and one of the
things you see with de novo lipogenesis
is it's pretty inefficient unless you
have to do a lot of it pretty frequently
and so in big carbohydrate overfeeding
study like longitudinal studies and by
longitudinal I mean like four or five
days when you have massive carb
overfeeding de novo lipogenesis is
pretty inefficient the first day and
then gets progressively more efficient
as more of its required so I mean
theoretically if you wanted to have one
crazy high carb day without wanting to
you know while wanting to minimize fat
spill over by minimizing fat intake for
that de de novo lipogenesis would
probably be pretty inefficient for that
day and you could maybe get away with it
slightly better but I don't know at that
at that point I think it's just kind of
mental masturbation and I will say along
those lines I do whenever I program in
like a very high carbohydrate refeed for
somebody who's in a fat loss phase and
they're trying to get very very very
lean so when we're in a you know I'm
thinking physique athletes bodybuilders
where every little ounce of fat matters
in terms of their body composition
whenever I give them like a really high
carb refeed day I do go a little lower
than my
point six grand per kilogram like I do
try to keep the fat pretty minimal just
to decrease the likelihood again the de
novo lipogenesis is pretty inefficient
for these kind of one-off high carb days
so I do try to minimize the likelihood
that we're gonna divert a ton of dietary
fat straight into a dip aside storage on
that day so I guess in a way I do a
slightly strategic reduction of fat
during those very high carb refeed days
but again as you kind of narrated as I
was talking through it it's really more
a secondary effect of the carbohydrate
manipulation more so than doing any
particular trickery directly relating to
fat intake so you might have a little
bit of non-linearity in there in order
to make room for carbohydrate while
preventing super easy shuttling of
dietary fat to the adipocyte but aside
from that III think it's it's really a
practice of splitting hairs okay this
one is straight to the point short and
sweet
turbo sauce seventy four 10 millimeter
belt or 13 millimeter belt man so so my
personal preference here I'm just gonna
talk about belts generally because I
think that ten mil 10 millimeter versus
13 millimeter is possibly the least
interesting question one could ask about
belts I apologize to turbo Saul 74 a
turbo sauce 74 it's alright don't take
it personally Jesus being he gets this
way sometimes so I mean the thing about
it is leather belts are gonna last
forever and I mean leather is a pretty
resilient material so you're not gonna
you're not gonna really notice a
difference in the 10 millimeter versus
13 millimeter for how much it gives when
you push out against it so like
if if I had to state a preference I
would probably say ten millimeter just
because they break in a little quicker
I mean maybe theoretically they're gonna
have a little less longevity but we're
talking you know is it going to last
until the heat death of the universe or
merely five hundred thousand years so
that's not really a major consideration
the thinner ones the thinner ones should
break in a little bit faster I think I
think the more interesting question and
something that people don't put quite
enough thought into is the width of the
belt so if you want the full what is it
is it like four inch maximum I think
that's the most allowed yeah it sounds
right yeah so do you want a four inch
wide belt or two-and-a-half or three
inch wide belt one of the things that
that I've personally noticed and that
I've also heard anecdotally from a lot
of other people is that the four inch
wide belt works best for squats but a
lot of people like a slightly thinner
belt for deadlift especially
conventional deadlift errs so I think I
think if you if you have the funds to
buy two belts or if you have a friend
that has a skinnier belt it's worth at
least experimenting with a skinnier belt
for deadlift if you're a conventional
deadlift er if you have the funds may be
worth buying like a two and a half three
inch belt instead of just the standard
four inch just to try that out a a lot
of people report that the four inch belt
interferes with their setup for a
conventional deadlift and a narrower
belt still helps them get more in
trapped nominal pressure without
interfering with their setup as much so
I think that is something worth
potentially experimenting with and
playing around with I think that's about
it for belt I was gonna interject I
actually noticed that back when I was
like really more focused on powerlifting
the bodybuilding but I wasn't really
tied into powerlifting community
wasn't on powerlifting forum so I
figured it was just me oh my god that's
a weird thing that I don't like but I
noticed I had like a standard like wide
belt for squats that was worked great
and when I would set up for my
conventional deadlift it it would just
as I was approaching the bar it will
just dig in in all the wrong places yeah
and I I'm a short guy with relatively
short torso and generally stayed pretty
lean in those days so I figured it was
either that it was because my torso
wasn't that tall top to bottom and that
it was just too wide of a belt for me or
I figured if I had a little more
cushioning in terms of body fat it would
have helped but apparently that's the
thing people notice no I mean that
that's a pretty common complaint Wow one
just random thing I was gonna throw out
there just just as a fun little morsel
for our listeners is people talk about
intra-abdominal pressure people study
intra-abdominal pressure and talk about
research findings related to
intra-abdominal pressure most people
don't know how intra-abdominal pressure
is actually measured which is like kind
of gross but also interesting what they
do is they they put a balloon up your
butt
and see how much compressive force is
exerted against the walls of the balloon
when when you strain and then when it's
done they remove the balloon from your
butt and that is how they measure
intra-abdominal pressure I don't know
how many times I got to tell you we
don't talk about but balloons on the
podcast I've warned you thirteen times
alright and any other facts related to
do you you talked about like gruesome
[ __ ] related to rodent research like two
or three episodes ago that is science
and I can't talk about but balloons but
balloons are science actually that's a
good point
yeah that wasn't that gruesome it's well
yeah it was gruesome
yeah was this shared blood supply yeah
yeah there's got some dr. Frankenstein
[ __ ] yeah it was like that that horror
movie where they like the caterpillar
thing you know
Human Centipede the caterpillar
yeah well is it humid butterfly yeah
yeah okay
moving onward we have a my my brain just
does not work today it's all good
what what was it was a that book the
hungry hungry cat give given the plot of
human centipede that would be a a very
not apt name for that movie no okay so
have a question from Mike Eric Oh
93 how long does the hypertrophic
process take to manifest both increases
in size and performance is it simply 48
to 72 hours or are there processes that
take weeks or even months to truly
realize something like that could
explain getting PRS and the fat loss
phase following says masking phase but I
think that's supposed to say bulking
phase have beliefs etc and little note
at the end I'm looking forward to the
podcast thank you Mike Eric Oh 93 yeah
well here it is and the masking phase is
bless you the masking phase is a process
that people go through every month when
the new edition of mass comes out so
it's a once a month process okay so
here's the deal when I started undergrad
and was started learning about muscle
physiology that it was still a time when
people would tell you you know first
eight weeks of a training program
there's not gonna be any hypertrophy
going on it's gonna be completely neural
adaptations and then after eight weeks
you tap into the sweet sweet land of
hypertrophy now my understanding is that
a lot of that research many of the
studies used
sub-optimal methods to actually detect
hypertrophy so there's nothing wrong
with like taking an arm girth or like an
arm circumference measurement but is
that going to be the most sensitive way
to measure that probably not so a few
studies that I would say especially
since like
2010-2013 there have been a few studies
coming out saying let's look directly at
the muscle using B mode ultrasound let's
try to do some type of correction or at
least account for the kind of acute
edema that would result from going from
no training to training let's try to get
an idea of how rapidly we can actually
observe some real measurable change in
muscle cross sectional area happening in
response to training and in reality we
start building some proteins pretty much
the second we start picking up weights
it's the question is at what point does
the accretion of new protein content
reach the point well among other things
the accretion of new protein content at
what point do we start to see the size
of the muscle increase to a degree that
we can say that's a significant amount
of growth some of the studies are
showing that's probably a shortage like
three weeks or so some of the ones I've
seen I know this this particular topic
is important to you Greg so I'm gonna
let you take the mic in a minute here
but so so the thing that it's important
to remember here is at what point do we
start doing the processes that
contribute to hypertrophy and pretty
much right off the bat now why did we
think that for the first eight weeks it
doesn't happen there's there's basically
two reasons as I alluded to a lot of the
early studies they just probably weren't
measuring it with enough precision and
sensitivity another thing that that kind
of clouds the the topic is the fact that
we see we generally tend to see pretty
robust changes in more of the more
neural aspects of force and power
development early on in training so when
people start doing resistance training
especially if they're totally untrained
within like the first four six eight
weeks we see that strength goes up that
disproportionately compared to
hypertrophy so that that's where some of
the confusion comes in so directly
related to the question some of those
hyper hypertrophic processes they're
pretty much starting right off the bat
um grad you have any what are your
thoughts on the question I mean I think
you covered it pretty well like there
there's two questions is the first is
when does hypertrophy actually start
occurring and the second is when is it
measurable yeah and I think you know
people used to say ah doesn't happen
until after eight weeks and now they say
yeah might happen in the first two or
three weeks I think it probably happens
from day one rides just when we use
really imprecise measurements we
couldn't detect it until eight weeks now
we're using more precise but not perfect
methods we can detect it in two or three
weeks I think if there were perfect
methods we could detect it immediately
because even in untrained lifters so
with trained lifters you see an increase
in muscle protein synthesis and not much
of an increase in muscle protein
breakdown with training with untrained
lifters you see increases in both
synthesis and breakdown but even in
completely untrained folks that increase
in synthesis is considerably larger than
the increase in breakdown so I mean
you're probably actually getting
hypertrophy from day one it's just you
know we don't have methods since Anna
sensitive enough to measure a 0.03
percent increase in muscle size so yeah
I mean I think I think in response to
the original question you know from from
the moment you leave the gym you're
probably growing the second part of the
question whether some of those processes
take weeks or even months to truly
realize people hitting PRS or in the
fast fat loss phase following a bulking
phase
I think that I think that oftentimes
people are surprised when they hit PRS
when they're not in a caloric surplus
because the assumption that people have
is that when I go into a deficit even a
relatively small deficit like suddenly
growth stops it stops if anything
happens you're gonna lose muscle
everything back slides pretty quickly
and pretty dramatically when in reality
if it's a reasonably small deficit
especially if you haven't been in it for
super long and especially if you have a
reasonable amount of body fat you can
absolutely keep gaining muscle and
strength in a small calorie deficit it's
just that the rate at which that occurs
it's going to be considerably slower
than if you're at maintenance or in a
surplus so you know if if you went from
a bulking phase into a cutting phase and
you're say three weeks into the cut
you're only losing half a percent of
your body weight per week and you find
that after a month of that you're
stronger than you were at the end of
your bulk that's not that surprising
like you're you're probably still
gaining muscle you're still having
neural improvements it's just probably
occurring at a slower rate than it was
when you were in a caloric surplus so I
think that I think this question is is
predicated on an assumption that a lot
of people have that you know as soon as
you go into any sort of deficit
whatsoever just the switch for muscle
growth is flipped off and it will not
flip back on again until you're in a
surplus and that's just not the case
it's just you know growth progresses at
a considerably slower pace now it does
seem that the question might be implying
that things you did during the bulk
essentially materialized in a delayed
time course so they don't really become
apparent until you're already in your
cut and so I don't I don't expect that
that would be the case that there are
some like super delayed adaptations that
you induced them during your bulk and
then several weeks later into your cut
they start to materialize do you see
that being the case it would kind of
depend what time course you're talking
about yeah because there is there was
recently a study man I I want to say the
the author's name is Gordon son I think
I think it's a Norwegian guy or a
Norwegian lab group
where they did find like Adelaide super
compensatory response to training I want
to say that was a study in untrained
individuals but I want to say they were
looking at knee extension force and it
peaked I believe either 10 days or 14
days after training cessation versus
like immediately after training
cessation so you know like theoretically
I wouldn't be stunned to see and I think
this would especially be the case for
someone who's maybe training with a
really high volume during a bulk and
then they cut back on volume pretty
substantially as soon as they start a
cut you're dealing with just less
accumulated fatigue right you know
strength levels may increase and kind of
peak I wouldn't even be shocked to see
like a month later yet if you're talking
about things occurring two or three
months into a fat loss phase you know
then it is probably just a matter of
well you know you are actually still
gaining some muscle just pretty
gradually any sort of like delayed
transformation effect I would expect to
see that within a week or two maybe
maybe maybe a month anything past that
it is like actual legitimate adaptations
yeah and I would expect that to be very
believable when it comes to performance
outcomes you know I mean anyone that's
kind of peaked for like a powerlifting
meet you know a few weeks before you can
I mean you're just trained into the dirt
take some time off you can kind of super
compensate and see that even with a
little time off your strength really
seems to rebound quite a bit when it
comes to hypertrophy though I find that
to be much more unlikely that you would
see did they look at hypertrophy in that
study as well they did so I didn't
mention hypertrophy because I know they
looked at thicknesses cross sectional
area and they took biopsies yeah and I
can't remember
so I want to say that they did actually
see like delayed add a patient's in
muscle fiber hypertrophy as well but not
in muscle thicknesses so essentially
maybe you're still like accreting some
protein but maybe you're also losing
some edema so the actual appearance of
muscle size doesn't really change all
that much huh I want to say that's what
they found but I don't I didn't remember
that for sure so I wasn't gonna mention
it yeah well yeah so I I think at the
very least you can conclude that there's
not going to be some extremely robust
pronouns change in like overall muscle
size like yeah oh now that I'm into my
cut now the growth is kicking in several
weeks later so if there is some kind of
residual carryover it's probably most
likely to happen very very within the
first couple weeks to a month maybe two
after transitioning from the bulk to the
cut I think two months is already
pushing it yeah so everybody's
substantially yeah it'd be a short-term
thing that I really want to bank on in
terms of expecting those gains to
materialize now one thing I will say is
it's not too uncommon to see people hit
deadlift pr's during a cut especially
folks who are maybe metal weights with
poor body comp into heavy weights just
because like especially if you have a
conventional deadlift as your waist size
gets smaller your deadlift setup
improves so it's that's not that's not
incredibly uncommon to see but I would I
think in that case it's kind of more
your techniques more efficient not
necessarily the total amount of force
you can produce at each muscle increases
yeah all right Greg got a question for
you here from Adam
Hass few weeks back you mentioned that
any decent hypertrophy program with
singles can be a good
strength program - I'm having trouble
trying to implement this into my own
training can you discuss that further
sure I mean so so basically if you if
you conceptualize of a model where
strength is kind of the product of
hypertrophy and neural adaptations then
if hypertrophy is occurring and neural
adaptations are either like positive
adaptations are occurring or you're
simply able to maintain your your
current level of neural adaptations you
should then be able to get stronger I
think a trap that a lot of strength
athletes fall into is they get their
first taste of high-intensity low-volume
low rep training their strength numbers
go up quite a bit they're like oh [ __ ]
like this is the stuff right here and
then they kind of get hooked on it and
you know there's kind of that meme that
you know like high-volume stuff like
anything higher than 5 reps is cardio if
there's more than 3 or 4 working sets
it's like what is this [ __ ] like this
volume is insane
basically when it comes to volume
strength athletes are a bunch of wimps
for the most part I have seen that on
social media where some little but I
swear to god they'll be like four sets
of eight yeah like yeah four sets a like
in the bodybuilding world if it's less
than ten sets of ten it's like not bad
yeah yeah so yeah I think people kind of
fall into that trap they they get away
from doing higher volume stuff it's
gonna be better for hypertrophy and then
they kind of find themselves in a
position where well you know you've
gotten ton of neural adaptations doing
high-intensity low-volume stuff really
isn't actually increasing your one rep
maxes anymore and now you've become a
little wimp who doesn't want to do
high-volume stuff so I think a pretty
good way around that is just to pretty
much stick to hypertrophy training while
doing some heavy singles as well to
maintain neural add up to
Asians or improve them further and as
far as implementation goes as long as
you have a decent hypertrophy program to
begin with just before your main lift of
the day just work up to 85 90 percent if
it's 85 percent maybe do two or three
doubles if it's a 90 percent maybe do a
single or two and then you know if the
main work is with 70 percent for that
day
you know after those singles or doubles
just drop back to 70 percent do your
volume work do your accessories call it
a day so just take the hypertrophy
program and add a few singles into it in
terms of how that that may look with an
entire week of training it kind of
depends how how your programming your
hypertrophy work so if I'm assuming you
maybe train each main lift twice per
week or something like that you should
be able to do you know couple singles or
doubles before every time you train the
lift if you're only doing each main lift
once per week that's probably suboptimal
for hypertrophy to begin with but you
should also have absolutely no problem
doing some singles or doubles before
before your your main lips for the day
the only the only way I could really see
you running into pretty substantial
problems are one if you're doing full
body everyday which if it's a pretty
high volume hypertrophy program that's
gonna be rough to begin with and you may
not want to hit heavy singles or doubles
on squat bench and deadlift every single
day in addition to fairly high volume
hypertrophy training or the other issue
I could see you're running into is when
I say heavy singles or doubles I'm
talking RPE 7/8 low reps so even at that
Archy you're getting a considerable
amount of weight on the bar but you're
not grinding stuff out if you have a
hard time holding yourself back and when
you get in your mind I'm doing singles
if I'm doing singles equates in your
mind to I'm hitting the max then you may
run into problems
otherwise I think implementation should
be pretty straightforward
okay so last last serious question for
the day every day athlete underscore
coaching asks Eric I guess I know the
answer but I don't like it so much we're
off to a good start dealing with clients
who constantly get emotional /
demotivated / irresponsible with their
own actions this is provided we set
realistic goals and I get creative
making plans that are suited to their
lifestyle and preferences no question
mark I guess the question is what do you
do with those folks yeah so I think one
of the things that I one of the things
that's funny is a lot of people think if
they just read a lot of science they
will immediately be a good coach I think
people forget that coaching in and of
itself as a unique skill set without
getting preachy a very important part of
coaching is being able to communicate
well with your client being able to
empathize with their struggles help
learning to understand what's important
to them so you have to really connect
with the client to troubleshoot this
kind of thing now people are going to
get emotional about their situation
because this stuff matters to them you
know what I mean and if they're not
getting emotional about it then that's
probably an additional problem when
they're no longer getting emotional
about their problems they've reached a
level of apathy that is probably going
to transition into just quitting or
burning out in the near future you know
or at least going through a rut where
they just don't give a damn about what
they're doing so the fact that they
still have emotions tied to it is
actually probably a good thing now
without getting on a huge rant and
getting preachy about it I've run into
situations where clients are a little
demotivated or even doing stuff where
they're like I did this and I know it's
counterproductive but what are you gonna
do and whenever motivation is an issue I
think it's a good idea to certainly you
don't want to scold the client I think
the more productive way to approach it
is have a conversation with them try to
empathize with them and figure out what
is the source of their lack of
motivation how you might work around
that but just have a conversation with
up and figure out these goals that we
set together these very realistic goals
why did we set them in the first place
you know like what were we trying to do
why were they important to you and are
they still important to you and it's not
some kind of like motivational raras
speech that you're trying to guide them
toward an answer this is a genuine line
of inquiry because if their goals and
priorities have shifted it does you know
benefit to try to force them into re
obtaining priorities that are no longer
important to them or something something
you you pretty frequently see is a lot
of times before you build a rapport with
a client where they feel like they can
be like open and forthright with you
what what they say is their goal and
motivation may not actually be their
goal and motivation like they may have
been insufficiently introspective about
it where like they tell you what you
think you want to hear or they set their
goal as something that they think should
be their goal or like what's expected
what they think is expected of them
versus like what they actually want to
do and what actually matters to them
yeah and so I think that's a really good
point and sometimes you find that a
person's goals and their motivations are
not completely synchronized or at least
their stated goal right so if you're
trying to guide them toward the stated
goal that like you said may not really
be truly tied in with their motivations
or they think it is supposed to be their
goal but it's not really what
what gets them out of bed in the morning
I think the only way through these kinds
of situations is with some honest
conversations and hopefully if you are
empathetic with your client you build up
a decent amount of rapport you can have
some honest conversations about do we
need to change our goal now if you have
a long-standing relationship with this
client and you know that they're gonna
regret shifting away from that goal
that's where it becomes more complicated
right and you have to say now
we go way back I know you and I'm pretty
certain that if we back away from this
goal and completely shift course you're
gonna regret that in three months so
that that's another conversation that in
some instances makes sense but trying to
work somebody through motivation issues
is difficult but you know fitness
coaches a lot of us are meatheads and
you can't just tough your way through
this one and just like force the client
into it and just you know say listen
let's make it simple here's the goal
here's what we said we're gonna do let's
do it
taking that like hard line approach and
being stern is a way worse approach than
being understanding and trying to to
really have an open conversation about
that I agree and I think something I
think something that a lot of coaches
don't appreciate quite enough is that
your clients may not be as into this
stuff as you are so I think it's hard
for a lot of coaches to empathize with
clients and kind of understand losses of
motivation and whatnot
because like most of the time if you get
into personal training or you get into
coaching it's because you you live and
breathe fitness and like especially
working out like it's not hard to drag
yourself to the gym it's something you
like legitimately look forward to doing
maybe your favorite thing to do in the
world you will probably have a multitude
of clients for whom that is not the case
and so it's less of
well why didn't you go to the gym is is
it not your favorite thing to do that
doesn't make sense to me and more of
like you know you don't really like
lifting or maybe you like it but don't
love it so you know how can we make just
the process more enjoyable to you and
what are you actually trying to get out
of it like what is a big enough carrot
that you're that you're pursuing to
actually make the whole thing worthwhile
because for a lot of us it doesn't
really matter what goal were pursuing
like you can just absent mindedly go to
the gym and train for two hours even if
you don't you know you're you're not
prepping for a meet you're not prepping
for a show you're just gonna [ __ ] go
lift but like that's not the case for
everyone and so it's it's a matter of
like trying to figure out what they
actually get out of it and how in how to
keep them more motivated by making the
actual training process something that
connects with them better and along
those lines sometimes the the a really
helpful thing to do is to figure out
what exactly are they avoiding when they
don't go to the gym like what is the
main barrier that we can actually really
strategically target so sometimes you
might talk with a client again
open-minded accepting conversation where
they feel very free to be honest with
you and you find out one of the reasons
that they're skipping so many damn
workouts is cuz the workout takes them
ninety five minutes to get through
mm-hmm and if you trim that down to an
hour or 45 minutes you can still give
them a hell of a workout in 45 minutes
and if time is their barrier that when
they look at it and they start adding
them the minutes in their head they go
up not today man yeah or you might find
that they're just the loads you're
giving them they're like dude it's just
when I see five sets of squatted that
I'm not driving to the gym you know like
there are little things even within the
programming the nuts and bolts of the
program that you can adapt another thing
that that can be really helpful is
giving your clients a choice when it
comes to their accessories mm-hmm right
so like if you say hey we need to do
squat this set
you know this many sets this many reps
here's your loads and I want you to do
this type of accessory give me a quad
dominant accessory three sets attend to
give me a hamstring dominant if you just
give them like little options like that
built in that can be another trick where
they go in and say I'm gonna squat for
15 minutes and it'll be fine and then
I'm gonna do you know 30 minutes some
fun accessories that I choose so it's
about knowing your client at the end of
the day knowing what they enjoy what
they get out of it what's important to
them their main barriers to adherence
and trying to manipulate those variables
accordingly
absolutely okay a fun little question
that that you brought to my attention
that you saw today when you brought this
to my attention I was honestly
flabbergasted generally yeah whatever
I'm just gonna read it does blending
your food render it less nutritious I
was I was offended I was shocked
sickened when I got this question and to
be fair it's like one of those things
where somebody just told it to this
person so forcefully and with such great
certainty that they're like it's not
like they believed it they were just
like what am I missing
soso I don't want the person who asked
it to feel embarrassed for referring it
to me but I think they were just so
genuinely confused it's like it's like
it was on such a different plane of
thinking that they're like I'm so
correct that I feel wrong about this
like because the PERT so basically they
had been putting like one of their meals
of the day in the blender and a very
muscle-bound
trainer told them bro you can't be
putting your meals in a blender because
when you consume food that has been
blended it has essentially already been
digested and you're missing out on
[Music]
some aspect of the nutrition I that's
where it breaks down for me and I don't
want to spend a lot of time on this
question out of respect for the audience
and hopefully not making them any Dumber
but when I got that question we started
this podcast if you'll remember to reach
potential people who would be interested
in our content but who are in fact
illiterate correct so this is this is
very own brand for our podcast it is but
so like whenever you come across
something like that and it's like if you
think that blending something is like
well you wasted those calories like
what's your policy on chewing your food
yeah for real
I mean it's it's like your mom always
told you if you chew if you chew each
bite more than five times what the [ __ ]
are you wasting your time on exactly so
yeah I just I didn't even know where to
begin I it's yeah if you can't blend it
how do you chew it I mean what what is
happening to this nutrition like what
aspect are you missing and to make it
more actionable let's assume I mean
you're not really changing the food by
blending it in a material way so I guess
the assumption would be that there is
some inherent value to the chewing
process in and of itself life hack
what's YouTube gum all day I mean that
would be that would be the good stuff
where you're getting that chewing
benefit without even having to consume
calories yeah I mean I guess I guess
theoretically I think chewing might be
related to cephalic phase insulin
response to some degree but I think
that's more just related to either to
just having like sweet or starchy things
in your mouth yeah with chewing being of
distance secondary important right yeah
yeah so anyway if you're out there and
you've been blending food and your heart
skipped a beat when you when some
muscle-bound guy told you that blending
food makes it essentially useless and
non nutritious
you're cool yeah I mean just just going
straight down anecdote highway right
here
Blaine Sumner blends like four of his
seven meals per day or something and
dude is far and away the strongest
single ply powerlifter on the planet
dude dude hasn't a thousand-pound single
ply bench squats damn near 1300 in
single ply
he's obviously deriving nutrition from
all of the all of the chicken shakes he
consumes theoretically but I'd love to
see what he could do if he was doing
food I'd love to see it
oh man so just to make this slightly
more useful in actionable so chewing has
been investigated as a weight-loss
strategy before I don't I don't think
there's I don't think there are any
longitudinal studies I could be wrong
about this but one of the pretty
consistent findings comparing lean and
obese individuals is that the lean
people tend to chew their food like chew
each bite more times than obese people
do and some like the cute studies have
found that when you tell people to chew
their food more times they consume fewer
calories in a meal and report just as
high of satiety versus just letting them
self-regulate chewing and chewing fewer
times per bite so I mean and and that
that is I guess something potentially
useful worth noting blending your food
and consuming things as liquid may help
you choke down more calories versus like
forcing yourself to chew more may help
you be a little bit more chill on a
hypochlorite diet just so you just so
you do get some useful chewing
information from this podcast just fun
little eating hack I guess yeah we feel
some obligation to bring some type of
utility
the conversation yeah all right so
speaking of which this is a
question-and-answer episode these
episodes are dependent on the questions
that you the listener provide so send us
your questions using the links provided
in the show description if you would
like some of your questions answered on
the show if there's anyone in the
Netherlands listening send us any
message at all please be nicer than the
previous ones that you sent if you like
the podcast be sure to like it subscribe
and leave reviews wherever you get your
podcasts you can find us on Apple
podcast and simple cast but you can also
find us on a variety of other platforms
those include Google podcasts cast box
podcast addict Spotify pocket casts and
YouTube among others I think that does
it for today's episode right yes sir all
right so we'll see you guys next time
and we're signing off thanks for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another healthcare professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it visit stronger by science
com to check out the products and
services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you